The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MARK SEIFTER: Hi, everyone.
A few of you may know
me from my tutorial,
but if you don't I'm Mark
Seifter I'm the senior TA here
at 6034 and these Friday
omega recitations are going
to be a little bit
different than any
of the other things
in the class.
All right, so, what
is omega recitation.
Omega recitation is in
this lecture style room,
but I hope to make it more
like a recitation or a tutorial
by, unfortunately
for some of you,
perhaps, calling on you guys
to participate during the omega
recitation, as we attempt to
work with some of the material
that Patrick has given
us the big picture
for in the lectures.
And if you've gone
to recitation so far
you may received a
little bit of enrichment
into how the algorithms work.
Well, here in omega
recitation we're
going to figure out how you
can work the algorithms.
And that's very important,
because in this class being
able to work the algorithms by
hand in some of these examples
I put up here, or
like Patrick sometimes
does in lectures to
teach you the algorithms,
is a crucial way
of demonstrating
that you understand how the
algorithms work, and we use it
on a quiz.
The way we use it on
the quiz is we-- well
this is an old quiz problem.
It's from last year.
It tripped up a lot of people.
So we're going to
go over it today.
I'm going to tell you all
the tricks that tripped up
a lot of people, in addition
to emphasizing tricks
that I've picked up over of
the three years of TA-ing
this course before, so
that you will not fall prey
to any of these tricks.
Hopefully.
I say hopefully, because
some of these tricks
I talked about omega
recitation last year
and people still
got tricked by them.
I guess maybe some people
didn't come to omega recitation
or they were just
very tricky tricks.
So be sure to come
to omega recitation.
Pay attention to the tricks.
Pay attention to how
these things are solved.
Ask questions if
you're not sure.
And when we get
done with the hour
together I'm hoping
that everyone's
going to do really well on the
rules part of the first quiz.
So without further
ado, if there are
no questions on that, which
I don't think there probably
will be, let's move on
to the problem at hand.
As some of you may
have noticed, it
is a Harry Potter based problem.
One of our TAs last year
was a big Harry Potter fan.
So what we have here
a series of rules
and a series of assertions.
Now if you happen to be real go
getter and have already looked
at all the past
quizzes online, you
may have already
seen this problem.
And if you really, really
have attention to detail
you may notice something a
little bit different in the way
I wrote it as compared to the
way it was written online.
In fact, you may, if you
have a lot of times a detail,
but you're not really
in on Scheme or LISP,
you may think the way I wrote
it is much easier to understand.
And in case you can't
understand the other way,
and in case one
of the TAs decides
to write it in a LISP-like
way again, let me explain.
If you look at one of my
rules, say if x is ambitious,
and x is a squib,
then x has a bad term.
That's rule 0 up at the top.
That's written in sort of what
we call in fixed notation.
It's easy, it's simple.
All operators are in the
order you would expect.
2 plus 3 equals 5.
There's another kind of
notation that is sometimes
used on previous quizzes.
And by sometimes, good
number of times, actually.
I'm not sure why we still use
it that way, because of the fact
that the class has move on to
Python, but we do, sometimes.
And that's called
prefix notation.
In prefix notation, the
operator comes first.
So for instance,
plus 2 3 equals 5.
The plus comes first.
The function, then, comes first.
In this case, the
function is plus.
So if we were writing this
in prefix notation, in fact,
the way I received it, when it
said, "if and x is ambitious,
x is a squib, then
x has a bad term.
The and went first and
there's a parentheses
which included everything
that was scoped under the and.
Does anyone have any questions
about prefix notation
in case it comes up?
Just remember, if things
start being written
in a really weird way
with lots and lots
and lots of
parentheses, whatever's
outside the parentheses,
whether it be "plus" or "and"
or "or" is an operator that acts
on the things that are inside.
However, we're not going
to deal with that now,
because I think the
most important thing is
to understand is the rules,
and the less important thing
is to understand
prefix notation.
And you can do a
problem at home that's
written in prefix notation
to test yourself on that.
So what rules do we have here.
We've got equals 0 through 5.
For some reason they
are labeled with P's.
They are often labeled
with either P's or R's.
The secret on why they are
labelled with P's is that one
year somebody labeled them
with P's for like "proposition"
or something like that.
And then other TAs looked at
that test and sometimes also
labeled it with P's and it
sort of down the line continued
to be labeled with P's,
and sometimes with R's.
So these P's are
these six rules.
The first rule is if x is
ambitious, and x is a squib,
then x has a bad term.
So what's the deal with
these question mark x's?
The question mark before an
x, or perhaps a y down here,
indicate that there's a
variable waiting to be bound.
We're not assuming there's a
Harry Potter character named
x, and only if that question
mark x, the mystery character,
only if mystery x character
is ambitious can that person
possibly have a bad term.
What we're seeing is any
character in the Harry Potter
universe, or not
the Harry Potter
universe, maybe a rhinoceros,
can fit into that x.
So for instance, if a
rhinoceros is ambitious,
and a rhinoceros is a squib,
then a rhinoceros has bad term.
That rule saying, for
any x this is true.
And it's very important how
we treat the question mark
x, and how we bind
question mark x,
when we do both back chaining
and forward chaining.
I'll get back to that, because
some people made some very,
very small mistakes
that really messed up
a lot of their forward and
backward chaining last year.
It was actually very tricky.
Jeremy, the TA who wrote
this was very clever,
and it makes it really great
case study for you guys.
All right, so Rule 1, if x
lives in Gryffindor tower
then x is a protagonist.
By the way, for
conciseness I'm going
to be using GT for
Gryffindor tower
when I write these
in later on, and I'll
use SD for Slytherin dungeon.
Speaking of which, Rule 2, if
x lives in Slytherin dungeon,
then x is a villain,
x is ambitious.
Why there are two things here?
Well, after the "if" we have
what we call antecedent,
that's something that needs to
be true in order for this rule
to match.
After the "then" we have what
is called the consequent,
and in this case there
are two consequents.
Anyone who lives in
Slytherin dungeon
is automatically a villain
and also ambitious.
So you can think of there
being sort of an "and
therefore" for the purposes
of both of those assertions
would be added to
the knowledge base.
Rule 3, if x is the
protagonist or x is a villain,
and x is ambitious,
then x studies a lot.
By the way, the scope
for this, just to be sure
that we're clear, is this.
So we need them to
be a protagonist
or villain and no matter what
they have to be ambitious.
Rule 4, if x studies a lot,
and x is a protagonist,
x becomes Hermione's friend.
And Rule 5, if x snogs y, and x
lives in Gryffindor tower and y
lives in Slytherin dungeon,
then x has a bad term.
So those are our
six rules that we
can use to understand Jeremy's
world of the Harry Potter
universe.
And we also start off
with four assertions.
Let me not underestimate
the value of always looking
to the assertions.
It's one of my white star ideas
that are up here on the board.
Let me see.
This.
Perfect.
Always check the assertions
before using a rule.
This really tripped people up
last year, and you'll see why,
because we're doing
last year's problem.
Our four assertions
that we start.
With assertion 0, Millicent
lives in Slytherin dungeon.
Assertion 1, Millicent
is ambitious.
Assertion 1 is what
tripped people up,
so remember that
Millicent is ambitious.
Assertion 2 Seamus lives
in Gryffindor tower.
And assertion 3,
Seamus snogs Millicent.
So those those are
our four assertions
that we've already started with.
Now the two things we're
going to have to do
are backward chaining
and forward chaining.
Now when you guys learned
these two backward chaining
and forward chaining,
raise your hand
if thought forward chaining was
harder than backward chaining.
I knew it!
I can prove whatever
point I want because noone
wants the raise their hand.
I also think backward chaining
is higher than forward
chaining.
Raise your hand if you
think backward chaining is
higher than forward chaining?
First of all, we have a
good number of people.
Second of all, since no one
wants to raise their hand,
I could just ask
it the other way.
That's a pro tip if you're ever
with a large group of people.
You can prove any point you want
by asking the other direction.
No one will raise their hand.
So I agree that backward
chaining is higher than forward
chaining.
And I disagree with Patrick that
we're going to get out early,
so let's start with
backward chaining first.
So that we make sure that we
spend the bulk of our time
with it.
The forward chaining,
well, you just
go through pretty methodically
and add new rules.
Backward chaining, you have
to draw this crazy tree.
There's a lot of places to get
lost in the middle of the road.
So let's do some
backward chaining.
And to do that, I'll do it
over here on the left side.
So when we're doing
backward chaining,
we have to remember a few
things that are written directly
on the quiz.
So you're not going to
have to worry about that.
But they're still
pretty important.
So-- actually, I'll
write it on here first.
I'm going to read them off.
So when working on a
hypothesis, the backward chainer
tries to find a
matching assertion
in the list of assertions first.
If no matching
assertion is found,
the backward chainer
will try to find a rule
with a matching consequence.
A rule that has something
in the then that
can prove the assertion
is trying to figure out.
So for instance, if
I was doing backward
chaining on Seamus [? Snaus ?]
Millicent, what happens?
I'm immediately
done because there's
an assertion that's
assertion three that says
Seamus [? Snaus ?] Millicent.
I proved it.
I'm done.
I'm happy.
We can leave, we can go home.
Unfortunately, that's not
what the quiz asks us to do.
Now, let's say that instead,
we were supposed to say,
I don't know, Seamus
is a protagonist.
Well then, we'd wind
up looking through here
and we would look at the
fact that rule one can prove
that someone is a protagonist.
And we'd curse and
try to prove whatever
is in the antecedent of rule
one, which is, OK, well,
does he live in
Gryffinder Tower?
Assertion two, he does.
So that's some really quick.
And if that was too,
fast don't worry.
We're going to go step by
step with the actual problem.
But I just wanted to give two
really easy problems, really
quickly, how it's
going to do it.
Let's go step by step
with the real problem.
Let's keep in mind,
backward chainer
never adds new assertions
to the list of assertions.
And if you have a
tiebreak, you always
order based on rule order
first, P0 through P5.
And if the same rule matches
with more than one thing
in your list
assertions, then you
tiebreak based on the
order of the assertions.
Very important.
Disambiguation and
tie-breaking are a big place
to get messed up.
So we're going to try
to prove that Millicent
becomes Hermione's friend.
And so I'm going to
abbreviate some of the things,
but not for the very first line.
So Millicent becomes
Hermione's friend.
We start drawing a goal tree.
Now you guys are going to learn
exactly what these mean very
soon, in fact, next lecture.
But for now, trust me when I
say these goal trees are depth
first.
And I'll explain what that
means because some people have
messed themselves up and spent
more time than they needed to
by treating the goal
tree in a different way.
Now, Millicent becomes
Hermione's friend.
Let's pretend that we
are the backward chainer.
We're trying to prove that
this is true or disprove
and say, well, it's definitely
not true with what we have.
So let's see.
I'm now going to
make you guys help.
And people in the back think
they won't be called on.
So I often like to call
on people in the back.
What do you think is the
first thing we should do?
Very first thing?
Yes, look for a
matching assertion.
Excellent.
Do we have a matching
assertion, everyone?
No, we don't.
That would be the world's
easiest quiz problem.
We do not have a
matching assertion.
Great.
So, since we don't have a
matching assertion, what now?
AUDIENCE: We start
to look at the rules.
MARK SEIFTER: That's right.
And do you see any rule that
could prove that Millicent
becomes Hermione's friend?
AUDIENCE: P4.
MARK SEIFTER: That's right.
You can see in P4, x,
which can be anybody.
Anyone is capable of
being Hermione's friend.
Great.
So P4 is our rule of the hour.
So we're going to use P4.
And when we use P4 to prove that
Millicent becomes Hermione's
friend, we're going to
have to add something
or another to the goal tree.
So let's see.
What do we have to
add to the goal tree?
AUDIENCE: We have
to see if Millicent
studies a lot [INAUDIBLE].
MARK SEIFTER: That's right.
Does everyone see that?
In order for her to
become Hermione's friend,
by rule four, we have to
see if she studies a lot
and is a protagonist.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: OK, that's
a very good question.
You're going to get screwed up
if you look at the antecedent
in backward chaining first.
It's backwards
partially for a reason.
You need to look
at the consequent.
Now why is that?
Well, let's say there
is a rule six that
said if x becomes
Hermione's friend,
then Hermione feeds x Polyjuice
Potion, or something like that.
Will that rule help
us in back chaining
to figure out if Millicent
becomes Hermione's friend?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: Some people
are shaking their head.
But think about it, will that
rule be able to prove it?
No.
Now, if they do become
Hermione's friend
and we want to do
some forward chaining,
we'll figure out
that they're going
to transmute into some
kind of other thing because
of the Polyjuice Potion.
But it's not going
to help us do the one
thing we want to
back chain, which is
to prove that thing on the top.
So we actually need
to look for something
that has our current
goal in its consequent.
Then we add on the antecedents.
As people I've asked
so far-- sorry, I
don't know your
names-- like Patrick,
have correctly given me every
time, which is excellent.
So notice also
that she didn't say
x studies a lot needs to
be added to the goal tree.
She said Millicent
studies a lot.
Oh, another question.
Great.
AUDIENCE: So obviously
after putting rule 4 there,
shouldn't we first check
the assertions-- check
on the assertions instead of
our conditions [INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: So
the question is,
once we put rule
four in there, should
we check to see if those
antecedents of rule four
are already in the assertions
before checking other rules?
The answer?
You're not only correct, sir,
you're exactly one step ahead.
So I'm going to assume I called
on you for the very next thing.
That's exactly what we do
once we draw it onto the tree.
You're exactly on the way.
Further question?
Perfect.
All right, great.
So again, we're putting up
Millicent studies a lot.
Millicent is a protagonist.
We're not putting up x.
Some people did that.
And of course it's an
n node as we heard.
We need them both to be
true or we're not going
to be able to continue onward.
So we have-- I'm going
to use m for Millicent.
Millicent studies a lot.
Also over here, Millicent
is a protagonist.
And we've already
heard that we need
to search in the
assertions before we
go into any rules for what
we're looking for next.
The question is, what are we
looking for next and in what
order?
This is where that thing I
told you about depth search
is crucial.
We are going to look
here on the left node.
And if it has any children,
if we have to keep going down,
we are not going
to look here yet.
There's a few reasons for that.
One of which is that we're lazy.
The evaluation, if
you learned about it,
is also-- if you learn about
lazy evaluation, is also lazy.
And if we can disprove
this study's a lot branch,
we don't have to do any work
with the protagonist branch.
We're done.
We're out of here.
And it's a loss.
So we're going to move down
the study's a lot branch.
And we already heard
from the audience,
we need to look to see if
it's in the assertions.
Everyone, is Millicent studies
a lot in the assertions?
No, it's not.
Well then, now we're going
to get to that question
that I had before about the
antecedent or the consequent.
Because study lies here in
the antecedent of rule four,
but we're not going to be
able to use rule four here.
In fact, that's how we got
here in the first place.
So the question is--
let's see, the question
is, do we have a rule in
the consequent that matches
Millicent studies a lot.
Yeah, that's right, P3.
That's right.
So P3 would give us
Millicent studies a lot.
And so therefore what will
we add to the goal tree?
AUDIENCE: We add both that is
Millicent either a protagonist
or a villain and [INAUDIBLE].
MARK SEIFTER: Yeah, she.
Turns out to be a girl.
So that's exactly right.
We heard that we
need to add-- we
need to add an AND node,
which also has an OR
node at the bottom
of it, because this
is a little bit of
a complicated rule.
So we have an AND node.
And the first thing
on the AND node
is Millicent is a protagonist
or Millicent is a villain.
And the second thing on the AND
node is Millicent is ambitious.
Actually, that is the second
thing on the AND node.
I hope that's what I said.
All right, the second
thing on the AND node
is Millicent is ambitious.
So here's our handy little tree.
Now this is where it's
important, as I said,
we're doing a
depth first search.
We're going down
along the left branch.
So where do you think we're
going to go next on this tree?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: Not quite.
That's a good guess.
You didn't say we're
trying to prove
m is a protagonist on
the right branch, which
is a very common mistake.
What do you do?
AUDIENCE: You should
go down to see
if there's a
consequence for m is--
Millicent is a protagonist.
MARK SEIFTER: Which one
of the two Millicent
is a protagonist do
we want to look at?
Yeah, the farthest down left.
That's right.
So you guys will
learn depth for search
on Monday, at which
point it will become
much clearer what I'm saying.
But yeah, you always follow
the left branch as far down
as you can.
Then you take the right
branch of that same branch
that you followed.
Great, so we're going to
try to find that Millicent
is a protagonist.
What do we do first?
Everyone?
Check assertion, yes.
Is it in there?
No, it's not.
OK.
So, therefore we're
going to try to find
a rule as we heard about whether
Millicent is a protagonist.
So, all the way in the back?
All the way in the back, is
there a rule that matches?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: That
matches in its consequent
that Millicent is a protagonist.
AUDIENCE: Um, there is a rule.
MARK SEIFTER: OK.
Well, let's give it a try.
Which one?
AUDIENCE: One.
MARK SEIFTER: Rule
one, that's right.
So therefore, we would have
to add what to our goal tree?
AUDIENCE: Another [INAUDIBLE].
MARK SEIFTER: Right.
And what's on that please?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: Yeah, Millicent
lives in Gryffindor Tower,
perfect.
So, our new thing that
we're searching for
is-- pretend this connects.
Actually, I guess
it does connect.
We're looking for m lives
in Gryffindor Tower.
Great.
And since it's depth first,
that's where we go next.
Great, we're on a roll.
So what do we do first?
Do we have that in assertions?
Some people say yes,
but the answer is no.
We have, in fact, Seamus
living in Gryffindor Tower.
Most of you said "no."
You're right.
The majority rules.
We don't have any assertions.
However, do we have a rule
with that in the consequent?
No.
So what do we do?
People are saying different
things that are all correct.
Backtrack, you say.
Go to the next.
We can't prove it.
All correct.
Put a big x.
This isn't true.
Now we'd look up.
We're on an OR node.
So we're not done yet because
either of those can be true.
So now we go back up, backtrack,
Millicent is a villain.
What do we do first?
Check assertions.
Is it in there?
No, it's not.
Don't worry, we're getting
to one where it will be,
where about 40%-- or 30%
to 40% of the class lost
points, very, very soon.
So, we see that
Millicent is a villain.
And it's not in the assertions.
So therefore, is
there any rule that
has that in its consequent?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: We're looking
for Millicent is a villain.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: Oh,
you can't see it.
All right, I will
move it down slightly.
It got a little bit off kilter
when I put in the parentheses
around the "and."
Hold on.
There you go.
AUDIENCE: If [INAUDIBLE] is a
protagonist or is a villain.
[INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: We're
trying to prove
that she's a villain, though.
So do we have any with
that in the consequent?
[INAUDIBLE] anything
that will prove
that she's a villain if
we fire off that rule.
Want to give here a
little bit of help?
AUDIENCE: P2.
If she lives in Slytherin, then
she's a villain [INAUDIBLE].
MARK SEIFTER: Ah, see that now?
It had two, so it was
a little bit harder.
Now some people ask, what
about that ambitious thing?
Can we like add that to
the tree or something?
No.
The backward chainer is
single-minded, focused,
and stupid.
Even though it's later going
to need to prove that she's
ambitious, it doesn't care.
It just sees the villain there.
Villain, oh, that's great.
As long as we've
got the antecedent
we are going to be happy.
This is actually
an important point,
not in this particular problem,
but in some other problems.
So by using P2,
we're obviously going
to have the antecedent x
lives in Slytherin dungeon.
And x here is Millicent.
So Millicent lives
in Slytherin dungeon.
All right, so what's
the first thing
we do when we see
this new assertion?
We check the assertions.
Is it in there?
Yes.
That's not where
everyone lost points,
but yes, it is in there.
Check.
This OR node is happy.
Now we move up to the AND node
with Millicent is ambitious.
So Millicent is ambitious.
What do we do now?
AUDIENCE: So isn't
the consequent of P2
that x is a villain
and x is ambitious.
I don't know if it's
[INAUDIBLE] or whatever,
but in our assertions we have
that Millicent is ambitious.
Is that necessary to let us--
MARK SEIFTER: To
let us use rule two.
Actually, no.
The question is,
do we need the x is
ambitious to be in our list of
assertions in order to use P2.
For instance, if we didn't have
the assertion that Millicent
is ambitious, would P2
have a problem firing?
So, it's a very
interesting question.
It's sort of what
actually I was trying
to mention earlier when I
said it's single-minded,
it's focused, it doesn't
care about the other one.
Because you might say,
well, wait a minute,
P2 could never
have actually fired
if it didn't have both
of its consequents.
But in fact, the backward
chainer doesn't care.
All that the backward
chainer is looking to do
is to prove whether
or not there's
a possibility that Millicent
might be a villain.
It's not trying to say,
oh, all the results
of some certain rules are
making Millicent a villain
and all the other things that
are there, like ambitious, are
in the database.
It's not the forward chainer.
It actually doesn't care.
This sometimes leads to
unnecessary computation.
But it's very simple, and
it's very simple to code.
So it often will probably
speed you up in the long run.
Like if there's, for instance,
100 thing in the then
and you only care
about one of them,
it would be a waste,
almost, to add those 99.
There's a follow up
over here somewhere?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Order m of 99.
And so [INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: You can try.
However, then at that
point, every time
you check the
assertions, you'd be
attempting to check those 99.
Also, you might not
have used those rules.
The question is, could
you make a hash table
with all of the 100 things
that were in the consequent?
And then, after having
made that hash table
since you were already
walking through those anyway
when you were checking
it, you could add those
to the assertions.
The problem is that you
might not necessarily
want-- with the backward
chainer-- you might not
necessarily want
to think that all
those things in the consequent
are necessarily true.
However, you might
not care about them.
And then you have
to make an order
and computation every time you
check that list of assertions
in the upper left.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: You don't know
what assertions there are.
You have to check the
entire list of assertions
in the upper left
every time you get
to a new node in the goal tree.
So each one is order 1.
But I'm not saying to find a
specific assertion is order n.
I'm saying every time you get
a new node in the goal tree,
you have to check all the
assertions you've added.
AUDIENCE: You have to do that
anyway. [INAUDIBLE] assertions.
MARK SEIFTER: Yeah, you'd
have to check for the four.
But let's say that there were
10,000 consequents of P2.
You would have to check
10,000 instead of four
if you added them
all after proving
P2 was true on the goal tree.
Also, another important
note is that you might not
use every branch
of the goal tree,
if there's like an
OR that's up higher
and you wind up using a
different branch, in which case
you'd probably have to
make a separate hash
table for every
sub-branch that you have
and then remember which
hash tables were updated
based on which sub-branch.
And then sub-branches die.
It's probably more
effort than it's worth.
It's certainly an
interesting question.
It's a great question for
a debate in recitation.
Also, I'm happy to
talk about it later.
I think that someone who very
intelligently made hash tables
and thought the problem
through, as Patrick said,
more knowledge can
mean a better-- well,
actually maybe he hasn't
said more knowledge can mean
a better search because we
haven't done that lecture yet,
but--
AUDIENCE: You're talking
about implementation decision
and using hash table might
well be a good way to do this.
The problem is that we're
presuming some things about how
the rules are firing and
what [INAUDIBLE] they're
firing that depend on the order
of assertions in the table.
So if we used the hash
table, we'd lose the order.
[INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: That's true.
That's true.
But I'm thinking like
if someone wanted
to make that implementation as
like do some research in rules
based systems, it's possible you
can increase the running speed.
In this class, we are
not completely as focused
on the fastest algorithms.
But I still think that
a cool thing to try.
Questions from
people in the crowd?
We'll start with you.
AUDIENCE: So ignoring
the hash table?
MARK SEIFTER: Ignore
the hash table.
That's a good idea because
it's a little extra enrichment
thing.
It's not anything
you would possibly
need to know for the quiz.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
So if it became
an [INAUDIBLE] are you
using this "then" statement
because you want the villain.
So along with using this
you get x is ambitious.
[INAUDIBLE] used after that,
another "then" statement
that we also use that
says x is not ambitious.
So how would you resolve that?
MARK SEIFTER: So
the question is,
let's say you used rule
two somewhere in the tree
to get that x is
a villain, which
then says that x is ambitious.
Then later, you have
x is not ambitious
somewhere in one of the other
rules that you then later need.
The question is, how
do you resolve that?
What does it do?
Well, first of all--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: First
of all, interestingly,
if it says x is not ambitious--
literally like that.
And I'm not being pedantic here.
This is one of
the tricks someone
played in a previous quiz.
You can have that
and x is ambitious
both in the list because it's
a dumb rules-based system it
doesn't know that you can't
have both of those on the list.
So if you have a positive
assertion in a consequent,
x is not ambitious in a
consequent, x is not ambitious,
it'll be happy to add
Millicent is not ambitious
while Millicent ambitious
this is already there,
because it's stupid.
Now if it had
delete Millicent is
ambitious in the consequent
and deleted something that
was previously there, that
would be an interesting problem.
It could cause mistakes.
Your back chaining
would probably
make the mistake
of allowing this.
However, this is exactly what we
do not, I believe as a policy,
do not have DELETE
statements on the quizzes.
At least previous
quizzes did not
have them, except
for in a hypothetical
of what happens if we add
a DELETE statement here.
I don't think we've ever
made people work things
through with the delete.
Delete would possibly
cause some issues.
Question in the back?
AUDIENCE: So, just
to check this,
we're doing backwards
chaining, we
don't actually add assertions
to your [INAUDIBLE].
MARK SEIFTER: Never add
assertions in backward chain
to the assertion table.
It's dumb.
The system is dumb.
I'm not saying it's a
dumb idea to do this.
It's actually pretty
fast to do it this way.
But the system is dumb.
The question is, do
you add assertions
or you don't add assertions?
You do not.
You simply go through, checking
all the things on your goal
tree until the goal tree is
either proven or disproven,
then you're out of here.
So, cool so far, everyone?
Good questions from everyone.
These are all questions
that are things
that often trip people up.
So, our next thing,
Millicent is ambitious.
We sort of-- the cat
is out of the bag
because there is a question
mentioning that there
is an assertion that says that.
But I direct you guys to
our favorite rule, rule two.
Shouldn't we use
rule two to prove
that Millicent is ambitious?
The answer is if you want to
lose four points or however
many points, then yes.
But if you don't
want to lose points,
then this is already correct
by virtue of assertion one.
So I guess I should write,
also, that this over here,
Millicent studies a lot
rule, this rule is rule four.
Yeah, that's rule four
[INAUDIBLE] and protagonist.
Down here to prove that she
studies a lot is rule three.
And then at the bottom here
we have what rules here?
We have the protagonist
rule, which is one,
and the villain
rule which is two.
This is correct virtue of A0.
OK, great.
So we've proved
this whole AND node.
We know that Millicent
studies a lot.
But now we're going to have
to go a little bit more
quickly based on time, and so
I will do the remaining things.
Anyone who has not been
called on is off the hook.
But that doesn't mean
not to pay attention
because there's some
interesting stuff still to come.
So, Millicent is a protagonist.
Well, good news, everyone.
There's one other reason
that I can do this
and that's that you've already
told me what I need to do.
Most is a protagonist, you
use rule one, rule one.
And check if she lives
in Gryffindor tower.
Now, will it do it again?
Yes it will.
It hasn't cached that
it's already tried that.
Now, hash table not
withstanding, caching something
you've already tried may be
a good idea with backward
chaining, but we do not
do that in this class.
That's an implementation detail.
It's another idea of
something you can do.
We don't catch things
that we've already tried.
We try them again, dammit.
And when we try it again,
maybe it'll work this time.
No, it never works.
It never works this time.
This fails.
This AND node fails.
The whole thing fails.
They're not friends at all.
They're bitter enemies.
Millicent does not
become Hermione's friend.
So now they ask
us a few questions
which are pretty easy to answer
based on the ordeal we've just
been through.
So, determine the minimum
number of additional assertions
that we would need
to add for Millicent
to become Hermione's friend.
But you're not allowed
to add an assertion that
matches a consequent of a rule.
You can only add an
assertion-- in other words,
you can't add an assertion that
will prove some other rules.
You have to add an assertion
that directly-- yeah,
that's basically the rule here.
Because there's
a lot of choices.
But he wanted one
particular answer.
And so can anyone
think of an assertion
that doesn't match any
consequent of any rule that
will make her be
Hermione's friend.
A lot of people say Millicent
lives in Gryffindor.
That's correct.
So, part three, your
solution to part two
causes an uncommon situation.
What is the uncommon situation?
And what should you do
to the list of assertions
to solve this problem?
Does anyone know what
the uncommon situation
would be if we added that
she lives in Gryffindor?
Hand is raised up here.
What is your answer?
[INAUDIBLE] That's true.
She lives in Gryffindor
and Slytherin.
So how would you fix that?
[INAUDIBLE] Yes,
you could take out
Slytherin from the assertions
and say that she only
lived in Gryffindor.
A lot of people gave the
answer to this question,
which is a perfectly
reasonable thing
to do in a rules-basis system.
They said, well, we
can add a rule that
says that if you live in x and
y is different than x, then
you can't live in y.
The problem with that,
among other things,
is that we asked for a way to
change the assertions and not
the rules.
And you gave us a way to
change the assertions.
That's the right answer.
There was another
backward chaining problem,
this is 2009 quiz one,
and I will leave it off
for the moment.
You guys should
take a look at it,
in particular with
variable binding.
Because remember, you
always have to bind
the variable that's
relevant to you.
But that doesn't mean
that you always have
to bind all of the variables.
For instance, let's
say that we wanted
to prove that Millicent
has a bad term, which
as it turns out, is
what we wanted to prove
in the other backward chaining.
Very quickly and without doing
the problem, can anyone who
thinks they're very clever
at backward chaining tell me
exactly what things would
be added to the goal tree
to prove that Millicent
has a bad term?
Raise your hand.
I won't pick out a
victim because I'm asking
this to happen pretty quickly.
No one?
All right.
AUDIENCE: You would add the
three antecedents to rule--
MARK SEIFTER: To rule five.
So what would you
add specifically?
AUDIENCE: For anyone,
variable-wise,
you would just have to
show that there is at least
one person who matches.
MARK SEIFTER: So can you
just sort of read out,
what would the first
thing say with the snogs?
AUDIENCE: X snogs-- or
Millicent snogs anyone.
MARK SEIFTER: Yeah,
Millicent snogs y.
That's crucial.
Some people did a lot
of different things.
Some people put
Seamus in already.
You can't do that.
The system is stupid, it doesn't
know that the person is Seamus.
Also, some people
said it worked,
because look, they're
snogging each other,
but it's the wrong snoggle
direction up there.
Because we have Seamus
snogging Millicent,
not Millicent snogging Seamus.
But yes, exactly.
It would be Millicent snogs y.
Millicent lives in
Gryffindor tower.
y lives in Slytherin dungeon.
So, let's give forward chaining
all the attention it deserves,
about eight minutes, which
will be more than enough.
OK, we still got
all these rules.
We've still got all
these assertions.
Instead of doing that horrible
backward chaining-- well,
it's not that horrible-- but
we'll do forward chaining.
It'll be really easy.
We'll just add new
assertions as they go.
Remember the tiebreak order.
Rules in order from 0 to 5.
And if the same
rule could fire off
with multiple
different assertions,
we'll use the assertions
in order from 0 to 3.
So let's see.
We don't have much time, but
with our four assertions,
let's see, what
rules possibly could
match with our four assertions?
Well, I'll figure out for you.
Do we have an assertion
about an ambitious person?
Yes.
But they're not a squib.
So not rule zero.
Do we have someone that
lives in Gryffindor?
We absolutely do.
Rule one is matches.
Do we have someone that
lives in Slytherin?
We do.
Rule two matches.
Do we have a protagonist
or a villain?
We don't have any
protagonist or villain.
Rule three is not going to
match because it's in an "and."
do we have someone
who studies a lot?
We do not have someone
who studies a lot.
Rule four is not going to match.
Do we have some snogging?
We do have some snogging.
So rule one, two,
and five match.
So m for matching, we
have one, two and five.
Everyone, which one wins the
tiebreak between one, two,
and five?
One, because it comes
first numerically.
Which one is rule one if x
lives in Gryffindor tower?
The only binding
for x is Seamus.
Seamus lives in
Gryffindor tower.
We're firing off rule one.
So new assertions, the first
assertion that we'll add
is Seamus is it a protagonist.
Great.
Now, there's one
other thing, and it's
the main thing I wanted to tell
you about in forward chaining.
About our old friend, rule
one, now that we've done this,
does rule one still match an
assertion in the database?
Yes.
It does.
But what's going to stop us
from constantly doing rule one
every time because
it comes numerically
before the other rules?
What stops us there is a
part of our implementation.
And it's a very important part
that people sometimes forget.
It's what I like to call
the no-impotent rules
implementation detail.
That is, if a rule
is completely,
100% impotent, it would
do absolutely nothing.
Then you do not fire it.
You go to the next one.
That's pretty important.
Let's say that you possibly
had a delete, which
you won't have on the quiz.
That means that if the
thing to delete is missing,
it's impotent.
If the thing to delete is
there, it's not impotent
because you can delete.
Let's say you have 500,000
things that you're going
to add to your assertions.
499,999 are already
in your database.
One of them is missing.
Is it an impotent rule?
No, it's not.
You have to fire it anyway.
You can't be like, oh,
it's mostly impotent rule.
No.
You have fire off the rule
if it will do anything.
But right now rule one won't do
anything because we've already
added Seamus is a protagonist.
So what rules match down?
Well, Seamus becoming a
protagonist is nice and all,
but he's not ambitious, so we
still don't match rule three.
We still match rules
one, two, and five.
As I basically just got
finished telling you,
the one that we're going
to fire off now is two.
That's right.
So, rule two is if x
lives in Slytherin dungeon
our only [? binding ?]
for that is Millicent.
And that will show that she's
a villain and she's ambitious.
So what assertions will we add?
Millicent is a villain.
And people stopped.
That's right.
Good job, everyone.
You remembered that
Millicent is already
ambitious from assertion one, so
we don't have to add them both.
A lot of people did.
They were wrong.
So Millicent is a villain.
The other part of that
rule doesn't do anything.
But it's not an impotent rule
because one of the things
is not on there.
Great.
So, what rules match now?
Well, as it turns out,
now that Millicent
is a villain and ambitious,
we match rule three as well.
So we match one,
two, three, and five.
What rule are we going
to fire, everyone?
Three.
Because one and two
are impotent rules.
We'll fire rule three.
Well, Millicent is a villain.
She's also ambitious.
She's our only match for three.
Therefore, what
assertion do we add?
Millicent studies a lot.
That's right.
So, Millicent studies a lot.
However, she's
not a protagonist.
We still don't match rule four.
Oh well, we figured that
out already ourselves
from backward chaining that we
were never going to match that.
So what matches?
It's still one, two,
three, and five.
Seeing as one, two and
three are impotent,
the only match is five.
So the only match we
care about, the only one
we're going to fire is five.
And the result?
Let's see.
x snogs y.
That's Seamus snogs Millicent.
x lives in Gryffindor,
that's Seamus.
y lives in Slytherin,
that's Millicent.
So what do we add?
Seamus has a bad term.
Simple, painless, it works out.
We're done.
And we got 100 on this quiz.
Hopefully you guys will, too.
Question?
The question is, if you have
a new assertion which matches
a rule but it's
really high number,
it's all the way down at
the bottom of the rules,
but it's new and
it has new stuff,
should we do that first,
maybe, because it's new?
Oh, you mean that it has a
lower number, a lower number?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK SEIFTER: OK,
so the question
is, if a rule-- let's say
that rule three made Millicent
be a squib.
Then yes, you'd
immediately not only match
zero-- zero would immediately
fire because numerically
it comes first.
You'll see that on some
of the old quizzes.
And you may see
that in tutorial.
If you guys want to do some more
practice problems in tutorials,
your TAs will have
that available as one
opportunity in tutorial.
But yeah, that's exactly right.
It happened that it
went in order this time,
but it will definitely
hop anywhere
it can in order to get to the
lowest numbered assertion.